l'ep 2016 ir pin banlieue de kiev il ya
deux jours des similitudes qui ne
s'arrête pas à ces photos en syrie il ya
six ans comme en ukraine aujourd'hui des
civils pris dans la guerre est au coeur
d'une stratégie délibérée
en syrie l'armée russe appuyer les
troupes de bachar el-assad en ukraine
elle est directement à la manoeuvre
les verts se ressemblent et par exemple
on a vu que monsieur poutine s'était
entraîné en syrie il a essayé ces
missiles il a détruit à l'aide depuis
quelques jours se dessine en ukraine une
stratégie déjà observée en syrie celle
dite des couloirs humanitaires
la russie a proposé d'évacuer les civils
d'ukrainiens mais essentiellement vers
ses propres territoires ou ceux de son
allié biélorusse en syrie damas avait
fait cette même proposition en ville
rebelle tous les corridors mise en place
nette à des zones contrôlées par le
régime syrien
sous l'apparence d'un geste humanitaire
l'opération selon ce spécialiste permet
de diaboliser ceux qui refusent de
parties les russes peuvent dire ceux qui
restent sont considérés comme ennemis
donc il est légitime de les bombarder on
a vu ça à l'air par exemple tous ceux
qui ont voulu résister en série et est
qualifié on va dire de djihadistes au
qu'il était légitime de les taper en
syrie des jarres après avoir prévenu que
ceux qui resteraient serait traité en
combattant damas et son allié russe
avait déclenché des frappes massives sur
v vi en ukraine ce scénario se répète
t-il cette école bombardée à tito mir ou
ce supermarché détruits a terni de son
pour certains des signaux clairs
c'est une tactique rue standard qui est
désormais appliquée au coeur de l'europe
les bombardements sans discrimination et
massive de civils vise à démoraliser la
population à lui faire sentir qu'elle
avait déjà perdu et qu'elle n'a pas
d'autre choix que seront ces prochaines
semaines le parallèle entre les conflits
ukrainien et syrien pourrait prendre un
autre visage selon des officiels
américains des combattants syrien
pourraient être engagés aux côtés des
russes dans les combats